hi there steve kaufman here and as you
know i like to talk about language
learning if you enjoy my channel please
subscribe
and i try to put out a video at least
once a week on
tips or
uh experience that i have had in
learning up to 15 languages today i'm
going to talk about what i think is a
very important quality in any language
learner and that is patience
patience and unfortunately most language
learners don't have patience they want
quick results
learning a language is actually changing
habits in your brain it takes time i
sometimes think that these techniques
that people use like spaced repetition
systems or studying long vocabulary
lists or even to some extent this focus
on grammar
is an attempt to short circuit a process
which actually takes a long time and it
takes a lot of exposure a lot of reading
and listening and eventually speaking in
order to create new habits
and it it is a matter of habits i was
talking to a an american who has been
teaching english in china and i asked
him what are the main difficulties that
chinese people have in english
and he said three he said first of all
the the third person singular the
present tense like he goes instead of he
go and that's common not only for
chinese speakers but for for lots of
people particularly if it's you know the
car that it was parked beside the school
is you have to remember that it's in
fact it's the only you know
call it ending with an s in other words
i go you go he goes we go they go
you go
so and it just seems even though that's
easy to explain it takes so long to get
used to
the second difficulty chinese people had
was he and she
because in chinese in spoken chinese
there's no difference between he and she
you just pick it up from the context but
in english there is easy concept easily
explained everybody understands it and
after five ten years chinese people will
still say you know they get about a
fifty percent
success rate my husband she i know my
husband he because you have to create
that habit
the other difficult the chinese people
had was with plurals because they don't
really have plurals in their nouns but
it's the same for uh english speakers
speaking languages where they have
gender if we don't have gender in
english so it takes a long time to get
used to
getting the gender right
we just default to le in french
people who have gender in their own
languages have an easier time learn
learning the gender of nouns in other
languages where they have gender
um
people who speak languages where they
have no articles they have all kinds of
trouble with articles
in english or in french or spanish
languages which have articles it just
takes time
i enjoyed uh fact i put a link there was
a
russian program called easy russian
where this the teacher there says throw
away the grammar book i wouldn't go that
far but don't rely on
the ability to kind of deduce the
grammar as a shortcut to learning the
language even if you understand the
explanation which is not always a given
you still have to put in that time of
listening and reading to create some new
habits so that gradually the brain
starts to create these patterns which
enables the brain then on the fly while
you're speaking to produce the language
correctly the same is true for people
who say i still don't understand i don't
understand movies i don't understand
this i was at a with a group of people
last night i didn't feel that i spoke as
well as i should and all this kind of
stuff
it takes time the language remains fuzzy
you're still stuck in old habits and
it's only through
a lot of exposure that you're going to
form new habits so
i just there's nothing wrong with some
of these other aids to learning if you
enjoy doing them
but if you think that's going to
short-circuit the system enable you to
to suddenly speak well or understand
well i don't think so perhaps some
people but that's certainly not my
experience so i recommend that people be
patient
when they learn languages and keep at it
and you will eventually improve
and if you enjoy hearing about language
learning
please subscribe to my channel
bye and thanks for listening